what the [ __ ] you you took an empty one
away and you put another full one down
Wow yeah yeah okay hey everybody you
know you know a little later came just
to get Darla I have a feeling it's not
the last time I'm gonna have to talk to
you three I will be taking my edible
right now now I don't like to take him
off stage because I like you guys to see
that I thought the cops were coming uh
uh I think that was quick holy [ __ ] my
reputation precedes me all right every
time she did I was like tip of the hat
to you like he hadn't breathed their I
think you should stop asking me stupid
[ __ ] questions The Late Show so I can
tell you this okay so he developed a
nickname that night you guys you guys
should probably get her out you should
probably get out of here we should get
hurt we should get her out of here yeah
we're good
yeah that's good no no no it's totally
good it's totally good all right
everybody it's okay sorry I love how the
murmur spread across the crowd murmur
murmur murmur remember I I know you're
wondering cuz I could hear the water
what's that that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I
was trying because she was being a
soldier this one in the middle I was
trying to let it go because she was
trying to play it off but she's been
throwing up in that glass for the last
15 minutes that is not drink that's
vomit but I was like a look at she
soldiering on because she was doing it
quiet none of you knew huh she was do go
you know I [ __ ] love it
yeah guys I'm telling you I love weird
[ __ ] I the reason I the only reason I
said it's time to go is because the
glass is full I didn't wanted her I
didn't want her to throw up on the
[ __ ] ground you know that was just
trying to be nice to the staff but if
she had a bigger glass believe me she
would still be here yeah I like that
[ __ ] that doesn't bother me at all it
just gives me something different to
look at I don't usually see that you
know you know what I'm saying I'm I'm
totally good with that that was and by
the way this is how she it was like a
[ __ ] soldier he was doing this Hugo
right so you just go woo and I was like
this [ __ ] means for real I was
like she is a [ __ ] og well I was just
like yo if she is in it to win it I'm
Who am I to kick her out you know what I
mean she's going a hundred I'm going to
hungry with her I can't believe you
didn't know she was throwing up right
next to you that's because I mean how
would you know like a [ __ ] bird or
something that she was feeding your kid
no that's totally okay you don't do
apologize it was really funny huh
I was thoroughly enjoying myself I mean
guys guys I was looking down and then
looking around like am I the only one
who knows house like this is the most
stealth repeated projectile vomit like I
don't even know that's a if that was an
Olympic sport gold [ __ ] medal tonight
yeah you think being a ventriloquist is
hard try filling up a large glass of
vomit in front of 300 people how did not
have anyone know David Copperfield who
you know all right that was so good can
I tell you guys so I was in I was in I
was in Cleveland and right about where
this couple is right here okay so I was
in Cleveland right about where this
couple is here there's a couple and
they're just like you there facing
towards me and they're at a 4-top a
round table there's two people behind
them and facing me too so the people in
front the dude is full-on finger-banging
her right full-on now your hands up yeah
yeah
not this dude not this - no uh-uh yeah
so full-on and guys not like a there was
not none there's no subtlety to this
they were not close to each other so
there was a space between him so he had
to reach his oh yeah he okay I'm gonna
say something terrible but I'm on stage
and he'd been he looked like he was a DJ
scratching a record like that
that's how subtle he was being in a
crowd full of people and I'm on stage
just like any but I had the same
attitude like I never see this that's -
I mean I there's so much you see all the
time so when you see something different
you're like no I'll take a look at that
okay I didn't want to watch her through
if you'd said do you want to watch
someone throw up tonight I'd have been
no but when it was happening I'm like
that's kind of cool you know full-on dig
it dig it dig it right and so and
eventually it ends and you know look the
truth of the matter is what do I care
you know what do I know what do I care
he's not bothering anybody nobody's
saying anything so I don't care right
but then he started talking at say at
his table and and that I don't that I'm
not okay with you don't because that's
disrupting the show for other people and
so I told him you know you got a quiet
town and he was and he said something
like just keep going with your little
thing and I was like
and I was like yeah man this is not
gonna this isn't I already know this is
not gonna end well for us like I said
here's what's gonna happen I just want
to tell you right up front like you're
disrupting a show for other people so
it's my job to ask you to quiet down and
he said and it's my job to tell you I'll
do what I want and I was like well not
you get to go man I said you gotta go
you got to get out of here and take your
finger banger with you and right and cuz
I didn't think anyone else saw it as
soon as I said it the entire crowd
jumped up and they were like pandemonium
in the crowd people the people there's a
balcony there people's badges like this
poor lady was just like oh my god the
dude this will tell you exactly what
kind of dude this was there are 400
people jumping around
chanting finger bangers finger bangers
she has her jacket over her head dude is
like this and I was like that is the
exact guy who would finger bang someone
in public yep boom hey everybody I hope
everyone had a
time tonight [ __ ] you know I am can't
wait to tell that story on stage [ __ ]
are you kidding me
you know what by the way you know what
else was really good she would do the
super drunk person face wipe you know
when they go it's like a long hard wipe
it's this you get all the way into the
[ __ ] elbow you're like ah drunk
people make me laugh man I know I get
super high but drunk people you know
what drunk people this is your favorite
is gonna make you look more [ __ ]
sober what the [ __ ] is going on you know
what are you saying to me right now I
because I think I understood all the
words individually but when you're
random L together in that sentence I
didn't understand what the [ __ ] you said
at all yeah
no I'm good I'm good I'm good
[Music]
[Music]
you